[Musique]
c'est d'abord de l'humain parce que
quand vous avez des familles qui ont
vécu pendant des années des dizaines
d'années dans un logement et que au
final elles ne peuvent pas devenir
propriétaire il ya une forme de drames
des ja cela c'est un drame humain et
nous voulons offrir cette possibilité à
toutes ces personnes qu'encore une fois
de pouvoir accéder à la mentalité
et la première fois dans les outre-mers
que nous signons un accord de ce type
avec un partenariat que nous avons noué
avec le département qui rend l'opération
possible mais qui porte sur un volume
considérable parce que mettre en vente
2009 d'un coup enfin ça va se faire dans
la durée le niveau de prix qui sera
offert à l'accession disons de l'ordre
de 40 à 50 mille euros devrait permettre
d'ouvrir quand même le champ des
possibilités pour des locataires qui
veulent effectivement devenir
propriétaire et nous allons pouvoir
accompagner ces deux mille familles ciel
le souhaitent à travers une aide de 6000
euros
six mille euros c'est la participation
du département qui couvre déjà les
fenêtres de notaire et donc l'humain
dans cela c'est encore une fois tout ce
qui nous préoccupe le plus
[Musique]